[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so you walk up to a couple of marines who are staying there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I walk up and go, excuse me, officers, if I may call you that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Officers.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there any reason why you're patrolling the docks?
[SPEAKER_01]: I feel as if your guys' presence, there must be something awry.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Captain orders to have a detachment down here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Apparently there was some bloodshed a night ago or so.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh my goodness, where?
[SPEAKER_00]: In a place called the Chart Room.
[SPEAKER_00]: Bunch of ne'er-de-wells were there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Apparently, however, the men that killed them were a little bit more skilled than many.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh my goodness, are we okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: As anyone is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: That puts me more at ease.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I could ask you one last thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have seemed to...
[SPEAKER_01]: I lost my company of who I was working for, and I have no idea how to travel and trade
[SPEAKER_01]: In this land.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you're a merchant?
[SPEAKER_01]: I am a merchant and I've been trying to trade back to Monmurg, of all places, to get some more goods.
[SPEAKER_00]: Monmurg shut down.
[SPEAKER_00]: No one goes there now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Order the Duke of Gratzel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Understandable.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just, I figured I would at least try and get some stuff back here.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've heard that there is a new dock opening up in Saltmarsh if you want to go there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or you can take your wares to Seton.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are ships that go there if you'd like.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I appreciate it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was Officer, correct?
[SPEAKER_01]: You can call me Sergeant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you, Sergeant.
[SPEAKER_01]: This place is a lot safer with you around.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: We don't want those foreign spies to cause any more trouble.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I shake his hand, but it's very limp.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like clammy.